pra que precisamos ganhar dinheiro pra
quem nós trabalhamos tanto trabalhamos
muito
de segunda a sexta sempre esperando pelo
fim de semana e quando fim de semana
chega estamos tão cansados da nossa
rotina que nós só pensamos em dormir e
para que tudo isso se analisarmos bem
nós nunca teremos dinheiro suficiente
estamos metidos no jogo que está
desenhado sempre para que possamos fazer
mais dinheiro para outros do que para
nós mesmos até o significado da palavra
amizades mudou agora network quanto mais
você pode me oferecer mas amigo você é
trocar os cartões e agora estamos com um
contato não durmo 8 horas
durma 6 do mar 4 ou melhor nem durma
porque já dizia o ditado que tempo é
dinheiro mas deveria assistir no mundo
uma comunidade onde as pessoas não me
vejo o dinheiro e se isso a comunidade
existia encontravam-se uma comunidade
alternativa lá nos estados unidos
hoje as pessoas não viam o dinheiro
lembro que produzíamos nossa própria
comida compartilhávamos é o nosso tempo
compartilhávamos nossas economias
uma comunidade alternativa que além
disso também treinava e enviava
voluntários pra trabalhar em projetos
humanitários na áfrica tomando café
dentro da biblioteca da comunidade
eu conheci o rappa e lembro que estágio
não falamos sobre como o mundo tava
louco e e como iríamos mudar sim em
dinheiro
rafa diz pra mim que pra nova vida ele
entrou sou três pares de roupa e 10
dólares
eu falei pra rafa que eu tinha vendido e
as guitarras e e tenha trabalhado tudo
paulo para passar aí era um disputando
com o outro pra própria quinta - as
coisas começaram a ficar um pouco
complicadas quando a comunidade nos
disse que pra ir à áfrica trabalhar de
forma voluntária
nós tínhamos que arrecadar 12 mil
dólares juntos para apoiar os projetos
já existentes ea forma de fazer isso
eles nos sugeriram é muito criativa uma
caixa de papelão escreve doações à
áfrica e vai pra rua vai pra frente do
supermercado ba e pede doações
as pessoas que estão passando com isso
nós dividimos em dois supermercados da
mesma cidade
eu fui que todo o dia segurando minha
caixinha direito nosso e ao final do dia
eu sou conseguir 20 dólares e só
consegui isso porque odiava ter que
pedir dinheiro né
como esperado a apostar no rafa
eu caminhei meia hora até um deles
estava já de onde o saque o que estava
acontecendo ele um celular do bolso
porque tinha que registrar aquela cena
não é posição a foto real que nunca na
minha vida imaginária que utilizaria no
ted setor tinha feito 20 dólares todo
dia eu com essa atitude tinha feito dois
e não poderia ser diferente porque se eu
encontrasse alguém com essa cara eu
também não daria nenhum centavo sem
conserto e falei cara eh eh precisamos
encontrar uma forma diferente de
arrecadar dinheiro porque assim nós
vamos demorar 20 anos
como é que nós diminuímos o sofrimento
de pedir dinheiro e aceleramos o
processo e aí no meio dessa conversa nós
descobrimos que tinha ótimos uma outra
coisa em comum entre nós que era a
música porque não fazemos uma dupla e
tocamos em bares restaurantes e assim
recomendamos
vamos o o dinheiro e diminuir o
sofrimento
lembro que conseguimos ou a primeira
apresentação por telefone o dono de bar
bm eles tudo bem tem espaço pra vocês
próximo sábado pode tudo isso em inglês
é perfeito mas peraí com o nome da banda
eu olhei pro rapha olhou pra mim
rafa com o nome da vaga e 10 segundos
criamos o nome mais óbvio que poderia
assistir
criamos play por áfrica durante seis
meses
tocamos em bares e restaurantes na rua e
quando não tínhamos apresentações
voltávamos a pedir dinheiro na rua mais
desta vez o suprimento é muito menor
porque tínhamos outra maneira de
arrecadar no nosso
depois desse tempo nós mantemos a meta e
conseguimos separar áfrica para viver o
sonho equipe e viver sem dinheiro e
viver com um pouco e ajudar os outros é
o país que nós escolhemos para realizar
esse nosso sonho hippie foi o malawi
malawi que foi colônia britânica até o
ano de 1964 é hoje um dos três países
mais pobres do mundo
as pessoas vivem lá com mais ou menos 2
50 por dia em média
ou seja se nós tínhamos um sonho de
viver sem dinheiro e acabou no país
perfeito pra isso é quando nós saímos
nos estados unidos a imagem que nos
venderam do malauí era de pobreza de
fome e de doenças de desesperança e
quando nós chegamos lá nós tivemos uma
impressão muito forte e o motivo
principal dessa nossa impressão que nos
deixou muito mais chocados era que as
únicas imagens bonitas que nós tínhamos
do país que eram os projetos que
supostamente nós vamos trabalhar não
eram assim tão bonitos
só então nos damos conta que nós saímos
de um jogo e caímos em outro
só que esse uso a pobreza como um
produto para arrecadar dinheiro
paralelo a isso nós começamos a
descobrir aqui
além da pobreza além de toda a
dificuldade malawi também tinha riso
tinha dança tinha música ou seja uma lá
e começou a nos dar de graça tudo aquilo
porque havíamos pago com o passar do
tempo eo brando com as pessoas locais
ouvimos falar de um homem com certas
características essas características se
assemelham se assemelhava na do ser
humano qualquer o que nos diziam parecia
uma descrição de um super herói e os
super heróis vão além do bem e do mal
o super heróis vêem uma realidade que
precisa ser mudada e faça o seu trabalho
curiosos e e com as instruções da nos
locais próximos a cantar
encontramos em tal o homem sentado sem
sapatos com as roupas rasgadas
esse homem tinha o poder de ver o futuro
especificamente esse homem tinha o poder
de ver o futuro das crianças
porém seu poder não pára aí
ele conseguia e ele conduzirá as
crianças para que elas de gastos no
futuro que ele tinha previsto todos
super herói tem um ponto fraco tem uma
habilidade e o nosso personagem não
poderia ser diferente
o op
ele podia ver 10 15 anos o futuro mas
ele não podia ver o presente e toda a
debilidade de um super herói tem uma
origem e admite ter tanta bala estava
localizada na infância onde a falta de
vitaminas básicas ea falta de um
acompanhamento um acompanhamento médico
e tiraram o poder de ver o presidente
isso poderia ser muito facilmente
evitado com a construção de uma clínica
de acompanhamento médico infantil
em conversa com a comunidade eles nos
disseram que fazia quase 30 anos que
estavam tentando pressionar a construção
dessa clínica e até então não tinha
conseguido com essa idéia em mente eu e
túlio pegamos nossas câmeras nossos
microfones instrumentos e decidimos ir
até a comunidade gravar um vídeo
mostrando a realidade colocar a no
youtube e novamente voltar a pedir
doações
jamais havíamos visitado um vídeo e
tampouco tínhamos acesso direto à
internet pra apostar na nossa página no
facebook mas assim nós decidimos fazer
um vídeo
porém com as idéias dias e trabalho duro
uma viagem de quatro horas pra cidade
mais perto pra pegar internet postada
depois de toda essa jornada
eu falei pro rapha temos o primeiro
comentário
e essa opção frente do comentário do
primeiro comentário do vídeo que nós
recebemos fazer uma leitura para ficar
mais dramático aqui me indigna que
personas que diz em ser voluntários
neste programa e tem pedido do acionista
em redes sociais para quantas personales
quando ele pretexto de ser projetos e na
áfrica quando não é assim e só buscam
envolver a seus países com dinheiro
que vergonha desta gente a ser plata
mostrando a necessidade e malas com
disse
antes de outros seres humanos para
agradar seus egos ianna relógios
não permitamos isto ainda bem não sou o
único que aqui que fala uma outra deu né
meu melhor
esse comentário foi feito por uma
colombiana e pensarem pra ficar um
comentário 100% colombianos ou fatores
que veio platão promove não só isso mas
tudo bem mas porque as pessoas que
tiveram essa impressão sobre o nosso
vídeo
o fato é que o vídeo não refletia o que
realmente não estávamos velho havia algo
num no ar que não ouvíamos captado
complexo de sentimentos uma energia
invisível inclusos pra aos indicadores
econômicos mundiais
essa energia é o poder que vazia o
mister trabalhava no futuro mas não só
ele
não estávamos rodeados de pessoas com
puder de crianças como puder de jovens
com poder de idosos como poder essa
energia era o que fazia as pessoas
acordarem às cinco da manhã cantado
mesmo assim com problemas de energia era
o que fazia as crianças e dançando pra
escola
mesmo assim nós tivemos um caderno essa
energia era o que fazia as mulheres
carregar os baldes com água e os filhos
nas costas e mesmo assim sorrir
essa energia cresceu e se refere se
chama se o condutor e quando nós
descobrimos o condutor tudo ao nosso
redor tomou uma dimensão diferente
passamos a desfrutar exatamente tudo o
que fazemos
nossos vídeos já não eram mais vídeos
eram oficinas criativas onde cada
cantinho da comunidade se converte em um
set de filmagem
nós desenhávamos storyboards escrevemos
roteiros
fazemos testes tratores com os moradores
locais
vocês não imaginam como era divertido
fazer estes testes com eles
eles levavam todo muito a sério eles
estavam nos carregando de energia o
controle estavam nos ensinando como é
viver com o condor a cada vídeo
finalizado editado nós voltávamos a
comunidade e com a ajuda de um notebook
nós fazemos o que chamávamos de cinema'
seia que nós exibimos nos episódios
finalizados para todos os atores e sim
eram atores e como todo bom ator tem que
receber o seu pagamento e o pagamento
eram as doações que as pessoas estavam
fazendo para que a clínica fosse
construída até as crianças que são os
alunos do mister shambala agradecidos
pelas doações das pessoas de todo o
mundo começaram a desenhar cartões
postais enviar para o correio como forma
de agradecimento contagiando todo o
mundo com o espírito comba a cada vídeo
postado na internet
a clínica tomando forma e mesmo quando
tínhamos problema roubo de materiais
trabalhadores que não lembra clica ou
doações suficientes
tudo isso vimos com olhos de o combo e
voltávamos recarregado de energia para
casa e tínhamos novas idéias para novos
vídeos de maneira que nós desfrutávamos
cada segundo as nossas vidas no malauí
quando você escuta o que faz o resultado
não pode ser outro
quase cinco mil dólares em doações de
quatro países uma clínica feita por meio
de uma ação coletiva entre a comunidade
de uma ceia quem forneceu os blocos o
terreno para a construção da clínica ea
mão de obra uma clínica feita por uma
ação coletiva entre o governo de malauí
quem forneceu os enfermeiros e os
medicamentos com a clínica uma clínica
feita por uma ação coletiva entre amigos
e desconhecidos que se deixaram
contagiar pelo espírito com dó e
gravaram seu nome na placa de
inauguração na fachada da clínica
por isso quando se pergunta foi cara
você morou no malawi deve ter sido muito
difícil né
nós falamos não foram tempos
maravilhosos onde conhecemos super
heróis de carne e osso pessoas e atores
de cinema local
pessoas com milhões de histórias que
merecem estar aqui muito mais do que nós
o condor é saber que agora tem cinco mil
família e desfrutando da clínica um
cantinho de lala o quando a entender que
antes de sermos de direita ou de
esquerda
somos todos seres humanos e rótulos só
servem para nos dividirmos porque juntos
poderemos fazer muito mais que nós já
fazemos ou quando é conhecer um
professor lá no cantinho do malawi que é
cego e é voluntário mas mesmo assim ele
enxerga o futuro através da educação dos
seus alunos
o com 29 ver com dinheiro sem dinheiro
o condor é viajar longe para encontrar a
si mesmo ou quando há é felicidade